there's a new poll out nationally of
hypothetical matchups against Donald
Trump
the poll is from Quinnipiac University
and it shows that Donald Trump is behind
every single one of the six Democratic
contenders that poll takers were asked
about or not poll takers I guess people
polled the poll takers I guess where the
pollsters people who were polled in all
six instances chose the Democratic
challenger over Donald Trump now we're
going to look at this but I want to say
right now I wish they had included some
other candidates in these hypothetical
matchups and I'll tell you why in a
moment but let's look at the numbers
first Biden versus Trump Trump is nine
points behind Biden Sanders versus Trump
Trump is eight points behind Bernie a
trump is seven points behind Elizabeth
Warren six points behind Michael
Bloomberg five points behind Pete Budaj
and four points behind Amy Klobuchar so
as you can see these are national
numbers now a few thoughts about this
number one I would love to have seen
hypothetical matchups against Andrew
yang and Tulsi Gabbard because their
supporters already they call in to me
all the time and they say David the the
candidacies of Andrew yang and Tulsi are
being suppressed and they will also
often say that their candidate yang
supporters say this about yang Tulsi
supporters say this about Tulsi they
will say the only person who can really
beat Trump is my candidate biet yang or
Tulsi clearly according to this latest
poll it's not the case that those would
be the only people who can beat Trump
but it would be great to see Andrew yang
in a hypothetical head-to-head against
Donald Trump
same with Tulsi now my prediction is
especially because of name recognition I
don't think that in a hypothetical
matchup right now yang or Tulsi do as
well against Trump as Biden Bernie and
Worman I don't I just don't think that
would be the case but as long as they're
not included in the polls we don't know
and it gives fuel to their followers to
continue to say they
are actually the strongest ones to face
off against Trump but their candidacies
are being suppressed look case in point
their names aren't even being brought up
now again because of name recognition
it's possible that you would have a huge
number of undecided if you polled that
way or that the numbers wouldn't be
favorable to yang and Tulsi respectively
but I still think that it should be done
now let's get to the caveats and the
problems with this type of polling
number one our election is really fifty
smaller elections this is an electoral
election not a national popular vote we
haven't had a presidential election
where we end up with a nine-point gap on
the popular vote or an eight-point gap
or seven or even six five in a really
really long time
most likely the 2020 election popular
vote is not going to be decided by you
know six points seven point it's gonna
be much much closer than that it's going
to tighten when it tightens the race is
going to be about key states that are
different makers what I mean by that is
a huge margin in California for the
Democratic candidate in the popular vote
is not going to help you win if you
can't win key states like some
combination of Pennsylvania North
Carolina Michigan Wisconsin Florida Ohio
so on and so forth now of course if the
Democratic candidate wins by nine in the
popular vote they are going to win a lot
of those key states by default because
the the 50 elections are individual
elections but they also are related in
terms of the mood of the country and the
general momentum but that is really the
way we need to be interpreting these
hypothetical matchups while these
hypothetical matchups do give us a lot
of important information about momentum
and the mood of the country and
favorability and skepticism of Trump
rightfully so if you see Biden plus 9
and Bernie plus 8 and you think this is
in the bag very very far from it the
other important thing to keep in mind
when you look at a lot of these matchups
for example Biden versus Trump 51 to 42
that's ninety-three percent of the vote
that means that there is another seven
percent that as of right now are either
undecided unsure or voting for somebody
else that seven percent alone even
without Joe Biden losing any support
like imagine that in that fifty one to
forty two matchup Biden gets the fifty
one but the seven that is right now
undecided goes to trump so it's fifty
one bite and forty nine Trump Trump lost
by almost three percentage points in
2016 and popular vote wise but one
electoral II that's why it's really
important not to read more into these
numbers than make sense even you know
for people who say Bernie can beat Trump
Bernie's up by eight fifty one to forty
three that's ninety four percent of the
vote there's another six percent there
which could go to trump so it's really
important not to get any false sense of
complacency because of these polls we
should not be lulled by these results
and especially when you look at what
happened in 2016 when you look at
Wisconsin Pennsylvania Michigan for
example being the difference-makers
North Carolina now I'm confusing myself
but I think you know the point that I'm
making it is really important that our
plan be not just get out the vote
generally because you know California
Trump's gonna get crushed and the
popular vote margin will be huge but
either way whether you win California by
one two or ten you just get California's
electoral votes these key states are
where we need to be focusing on get out
the vote and when the eventual
Democratic nominee is decided I hope
that they actually will do that let me
know what you think about the
hypothetical matchups let me know if you
agree disagree that Andrew yang and
Tulsi should be included just so we can
get the numbers because their followers
insist that they are really the ones
that can defeat Donald Trump and in the
meantime we will continue covering this
on the David Pakman show Instagram page
at David Pakman show and while you are
there I ask you to also humbly follow me
on instagram at david pakman one of our
sponsors is privacy calm they're giving
you $5 when you sign up for their
completely free service at privacy calm
slash Pakman I've been using privacy for
a little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
here's how it works takes just a couple
of minutes to set up anytime you buy
something online or on the phone instead
of actually using your real credit card
number the privacy app and the browser
plugin let you give each company a
randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even autofill the card number with one
click and the payment is taken out of
your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to twelve of these virtual
credit cards a month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them any time you want so
when you do this it means you're not
going to be charged when you don't want
to be because you can destroy the
virtual card number right after using it
which for instance I love using free
trials because I know I won't be charged
when the trial is over if I use a
virtual credit card number you're
keeping your identity private by not
telling companies who you are you're
keeping your bank or credit card info
protected against data breaches and
identity theft and it's free there's no
catch whatsoever but if you want privacy
also offers a ten dollar a month plan
that gives you one percent cashback and
lets you create 36 credit cards a month
and a twenty five dollar a month plan
tailored more for small businesses where
you can create sixty card numbers a
month and much more but definitely go
ahead and at least get started with the
free plan you'll protect your financial
info companies can't charge you
unexpectedly and like I said you'll get
five dollars to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm slash Pakman